Americans worked an average of 1780
hours in 2017 according to the
Organisation for Economic Cooperation
and Development that's 85 hours more
than the average worker in Canada 104
more than those in Australia and 266
more hours than employees in the United
Kingdom in a new article the Atlantic's
Derek Thompson says Americans look for
meaning and purpose in their jobs in the
way some used to turn to religion he
calls this work is amande says it leads
to spending more time at work Eric
welcome great to be here thank you so
what is work ISM that's maybe different
than just people who stay at work a long
time yeah I think there are lots of
people who stay at work a long time just
because they have to work ISM is people
staying at work a long time because they
think it is their most important source
of meaning and purpose and transcendence
everything that we've historically
looked to traditional religions for the
community transcendence
self-actualization I think increasingly
Americans in particular elite
college-educated Americans are turning
to work for that very thing and our jobs
kind of cocooning us a little bit by
putting the ping-pong table and the
foosball table and the comfy thing we
can all relax on create a kind of
community sense and feeling which
exacerbates that or does that
exacerbated it I think it does yeah I
think it really does I think in many
ways you know these organizations that
have the ping-pong table and have you
know the kale and smoothie bar they
bring people together who think that
they're among a group that wants to be
there that wants to be there you know 80
hours 90 hours a week but this is I
think what sociologists sometimes called
pluralistic ignorance people are
inwardly believing one thing and out
really doing something else if you put
sort of injected truth serum into a lot
of these people I think they would tell
you I'd love to work 30% less I just
thought everyone else around me wanted
to work more and this in many ways is
how religion starts religions start by
making people think that they have to
participate in rituals that they might
privately disagree with in order to
create a kind of public trend although
one helps you in the afterlife the other
one just gets you there faster this is a
really important point the great thing
about monotheistic faiths is that
they're unfalsifiable you
God's not gonna come down and say you
know you're wrong actually about
commandment number four you missed it
you misheard me there you know there's
not going to be a moment where we
realized it's something about the
afterlife as it is there isn't gonna
happen work is falsified all the time
success is falsified all the time
getting that EVP spot at your company is
a one in ten shot getting into heaven
isn't the same sort of thing so I don't
think we should put our faith in jobs
that weren't designed to bear that
burden we are asking in our jobs for
better bread than can be made of though
where does family and work life balance
fall into work ISM I think that in many
ways people feel like you know work is
pulling in one way and life is pulling
in another way and this is especially
important when we're talking about
meaning and passion and I think the
research from positive psychology tells
us that for most people fulfillment and
passion in their life actually comes
from their life and not from their work
and it makes me a little bit scared of
having all these people speaking to tens
of thousands or millions of college
graduates saying find your passion in
labor force yeah well look at the labor
force it wasn't designed to bear our
passions it was designed to be a
capitalist economy so I feel like we're
setting people up for disillusionment
I'm gonna direct people to your article
because it's really good you said I'm
actually writing about myself